42 years after her murder metro says
they now know who killed kim bryant the
department made that announcement today
in the cold case homicide joe mohler was
at the press conference he shows us how
they found out who did it
kim bryant was just 16 years old when
she was killed new dna testing links
johnny blake peterson to the crime
bryant a western high school student
went missing in 1979 she was kidnapped
raped and murdered her body was found in
the desert the case went cold but after
a donation to the department they were
able to send dna from her autopsy to a
lab in texas that lab linked dna found
on her body to the killer's family
members lieutenant ray spencer read a
statement from brian's father kim was a
beautiful girl with a bright future and
it makes me happy that something is
being done to help solve cases such as
hers police do not know if bryant and
peterson knew each other they did say
peterson briefly went to western high as
well peterson did have a criminal
background unfortunately there will be
no arrest or trial as peterson did die
back in 1993 reporting at metro
headquarters joe mohler live local now